since the violence in Sudan broke out
we've been working very hard to ensure
the safety of both our diplomats and
also British Nationals I'm really
pleased that over the weekend we were
able to safely evacuate our diplomats
and their families and we now have an
operation underway to evacuate British
Nationals the first flight has already
left there will be more flights this
evening and into tomorrow all of that is
only possible because of the hard work
of lots of people behind me in the
foreign office crisis center here in
London that brings together people from
across government but also of course our
team's armed forces and others on the
ground in Sudan I'm very grateful to all
of them for making this possible okay
like you said there's a huge amount of
work going on and people are clearly
working around the clock here trying to
offer assistance and yet why is it that
many people that we and others speak to
in Khartoum say that the foreign office
isn't helping them are failing them even
like what's going wrong
well I've been sharing cobras on this
situation since Thursday every day since
Thursday and I'm pleased that we were
actually one of the first countries to
safely evacuate our diplomats and their
families and it was right that we
prioritized them because they were being
specifically targeted now the security
situation on the ground in Sudan is
complicated it is volatile and we wanted
to make sure that we can put in place
processes that are going to work for
people are going to be safe and
effective and we now have over a hundred
people on the ground in Sudan the first
flight has already left with British
Nationals who have more flights this
evening and we'll have many more into
tomorrow and that is down to the hard
work of lots of people and we will keep
at it we've actually already contacted
over a thousand people in Sudan we've
spoken to hundreds that's what the
people behind me have been doing they're
making their way to the Airfield and we
will safely evacuate them as quickly as
we can so the day today started with
people being told not to come to the
Airfield until they're called forward
and then that advice was updated to a
general call for people to come forward
it does seem a bit confusing like are
you worried that this lack of clarity
could lead to empty seats on planes or a
mad Scramble with lots of people coming
to the airport like are you able to say
is this first flight full or are there
empty seats well it's exactly because we
want to make sure that all the
evacuations are happening in an
effective and safe manner that we decide
how best to call people forward that
evolves depending on the situation on
the ground the first fly the left took
everybody that was at the Airfield and
eligible is on that flight there will be
more flights this evening and then many
more into tomorrow we're contacting
people both directly but also we've
issued out a general call for people
they can make their way to the Airfield
they will then be processed and safely
evacuated at the same time we can't
guarantee the the long-term
sustainability of the Airfield that
we're currently using so we're also
exploring and standing up other
alternative routes for safe exit from
Sudan that work is also underway in
potentially in Port Sudan as one of
those leading options so we're doing
that work in parallel as well but rest
assured we're in contact with everybody
the Airfield is now working flights are
taking off British Nationals have
already left and we will keep getting as
many of them as we can on the planes as
we as we go forward and can you say how
long this is going to last like how long
will this Mission continue and can you
guarantee that you won't rest until
every British national is safe well the
security situation in Sudan is
complicated and it is volatile we're
taking advantage of the window that we
have at the moment where there is as you
know a temporary ceasefire to safely
evacuate British Nationals what we're
also doing is working together with
International Partners to try and bring
about a more sustained ceasefire and
hopefully a return to civilian
government in Sudan that's the best
solution to avoid more humanitarian
impact that work is also ongoing one of
the things that this crisis center
brings together is all aspects of our
response to Sudan it's right that we
focus on that as well but we now as I
said we've got an operation up and
running with over 100 people on the
ground thousands of people in Sudan
British Nationals being contacted and
hopefully many of them will make their
way to the airport where we have the
ability now to evacuate them safely over
the next 24 hours in very significant
numbers and that's what we're determined
to deliver because check for the pool
that first flight it is full or there
are empty seats now the first flight has
taken everybody that was there at the
Airfield who could be processed we
actually have two more flights this
evening and then many more into tomorrow
which we'll be able to evacuate several
hundred people if they can make their
way to the Airfield but that's why it's
so important that we contact everybody
and that's what the team here would do I
said over a thousand people contacted
hundreds spoken to directly and as they
can make their way for the Airfield we
have the team on the ground there to
process them make sure they're eligible
and then get them on the planes and get
them safely home that operation is now
up and running but it's only thanks to
the hard work of all the people behind
me and everyone on the ground there
they're doing a fantastic job they're
walking working 24 7 to make this
possible and we will keep at it and
please could you forgive me a domestic
question uh just one last one please
um so Dominic Robb has obviously
resigned last week saving you from that
decision but why didn't you sack him and
are you a hundred percent confident that
he will be the last to leave your
government for 4 falling short of
ministerial standards well when these
complaints first came to light I
appointed an independent leading
Barrister to look at them Dominic Rod
said at the time if uh if that
investigation found against him that he
would resign and he's been good to his
word and has done that and I think it's
now right that we move forward